now france has technically lifted its
coronavirus blockade and will now
allow truck drivers stranded in southern
england to cross
into the country but they first have to
test negative for covet 19.
france is also allowing passengers from
other eu countries to travel
from britain borders were closed to
travelers from the uk on sunday after a
fast spreading coronavirus variant
was identified there britain says it
will take two to three days to process
the current backlog of vehicles
what a way to spend the last days before
christmas
hundreds of trucks cued on the road to
dover
in a line that stretches on and on and
on
for dozens of kilometers some pulled
over into the service stations
it's here we meet eberhard schweitzer
from germany
we want to spend christmas at home with
our family it'll be very bad if we can't
my wife has been really upset since she
found out about all this
but what can i do
these drivers couldn't have known the
french border would suddenly slam
shut on sunday since then they've been
stranded here
some forced to literally live life on
the road their anger growing as the
hours pass
why i'm here two days three days as
people here
stay here no small children in the booth
don't have food don't have water the
closure of dover
didn't just hurt drivers one-fifth of
all goods bound for britain passed
through the ports
supermarkets had warned of shortages of
basic goods if the port had remained
closed much longer
a key demand from france before
reopening its border
was testing the drivers getting those
tests up and running you know
can happen relatively quickly but in
terms of the details of that
that is something that both the
transport sector and his counterpart
will be discussing right now so i don't
want to speculate in terms of
you know the nature of the testing and
how soon that could be up and running
all truckers will now be tested but that
is set to be a huge logistical challenge
with thousands stuck on various roads
and time is of the essence
only when test results come back
negative will the stranded truckers
finally be allowed to head home the news
will come as a relief to british
supermarkets
which had already seen panic buying and
some
shortages of specialized products
long lines are a common site so close to
christmas
but empty shelves are not britain's in
many parts of the country
worried about potential food shortages
rushed to supermarkets in recent days
panic buying is leading to empty shelves
in many markets
choices are limited for christmas
shopping after all much of the country
has re-entered strict lockdowns
supermarkets are among the few places
allowed to open some shoppers take it in
stride
i was pretty good i think most people
are sort of just
going about their business the shelves
are pretty empty in the
christmasy goods area so i guess more
people are
shopping here because all the other
shops are shut now
the cause of the current shortages are
likely due to panic buying alone
distributors say shelves could stay
empty as the effect of the border
closure makes its way down the supply
chain
britons may get their christmas dinner
as usual this year
but whether stores will be fully stocked
after the festive season
seems unlikely
let's get more on this from james sibley
he's the head of international affairs
at the uk's federation of
small business welcome to the program
james what do you hear from your members
how important
is it to them that this border issue is
resolved
good morning it's incredibly important
um so the route particularly
uh the dover calais crossing is
incredibly important to businesses in
all kinds of sectors but particularly
those who are exporting perishable goods
so things like vegetables sea fish
that kind of thing and it's really vital
that this is now reopened and it's
it's equally vital that we get traffic
moving as quickly as possible
how dependent are your members on
cross-border deliveries
uh from the eu
so very dependent i mean half of the
uk's goods exports
are to the eu and you know about 20
of our exports go via the dover calais
crossing alone
and so the keeping across board of trade
moving is incredibly important
and then of course there's imports as
well particularly this kind of year this
time of year
uh imports of fresh food is particularly
prevalent from the eu
as as we don't grow certain things in
the uk during winter
now the root of this uh whole dispute
was this new variant of the
coronavirus uh spreading through britain
now as a result of that there is a
third lockdown in large parts of the
country how's that
impacting uh small businesses
it's having an incredible impact and so
we have um
the latest estimate is that there's over
170 000 businesses across the south
east and london that have been ordered
to close uh
due to the tier four restrictions that
have been brought in by the government
in response to the latest
uh mutant form of covid and it's
particularly
hard for businesses at the moment
because we are when the restrictions
were brought in it was just a week
before christmas this is one of the
busiest times of year
particularly for those in retail and
hospitality and they've been ordered to
shut at the last moment
and the other thing is that over the
past few months we've had um you know
business
in order to reopen to shut again new
restrictions have come in they've had to
familiarize themselves with
it's been a really tough tough um well
tough year but also a tough end to the
year
now james these long lines of trucks
that that were
still seeing despite this border issue
being resolved is this a vivid
example of what the situation might look
like
if there is no post brexit trade deal
between
britain and the eu for which there's
only a week left to strike
so we're likely to see disruption
particularly
in the first half of next year and you
are likely to see
cues of lorries but that's primarily
because the time taken to move through
the border
is going to be is going to take much
longer due to the increase in checks
um due to leaving the customs union in a
single market where we're hopefully
unlikely to see
a repetition of the border being fully
closed um
due to public health and policy but we
are likely to see disruption
uh for sure and that unfortunately is
probably going to mean cues and
disruptions to the supply chain
james sibley of the uk federation of
small businesses
thank you for talking to dw
thank you
let's go right to london dw's biggett
mass is standing by for us there
hi burgett france has now eased its ban
on travel
from britain on the condition of a
negative coronavirus test
how are those plans for testing going
sumi as far as i know it's still in
preparation
but supposedly really imminent and the
army is
supposed to help the nhs workers and
clearing up this huge
backlog of trucks there in dover and
roundover there were pictures of some
scuffles between
truck drivers would look to be truck
drivers and the police
because there is obviously frustration
with people having been stranded there
not having enough food not having enough
toilet facilities and they desperately
want to go home for christmas
as as we have seen and report but it's
on the way and
hopefully in the next days the backlog
will be cleared
what about travelers who are stranded in
the uk who are trying to reach other
countries
when will they be able to leave
the first ferries have been disembarking
in france there's a huge relief that the
french have now
relented it's been a very tense
diplomatic issue there were many
commentators
newspapers here in the uk who have
blamed the french president
emmanuel macron and one
tabloid paper even called him a cove
idiot
so quite derogatory uh term
it's it's a huge relief that now many
countries not just
france um are thinking or have started
opening the borders again we have seen
uh the bulgarian government uh issuing a
statement that bulgarian citizens
subject to a negative
covetous can now return home so slowly
the uh
the situation in in other countries uh
not just
european countries but countries across
the world
it looks like there might be an easing
of of the ban
on on uk travelers and on the the
outbound
flights from the uk obviously subject to
to negative cove tests and this is a
practical uh
hurdle for many people who want to to
leave the uk and return home because
that needs to be
arranged and needs to be done in time so
it's still an organizational nightmare
for the uk government
and there have been concerns about the
effect of these border closures on food
supply so
there in london are you starting to see
shortages of essential goods
personally i haven't seen any shortages
in the supermarkets i've visited in the
last days
but there are pictures of empty shelves
and one big supermarket chain
has limited the selling of essential
goods like for example
toilet papers and that obviously
reminded people of
of the early days uh in the corona virus
crisis where
the shelves were emptied and people were
panic buying but
with everything hopefully returning to
normal
our soon shortages should be averted
it's fresh produce mostly that
supermarkets and also hauliers have been
warning
could be short within the next days if
the situation
isn't clearing in the ports because the
uk imports most of its fresh
produce from the continent from the eu
fruit and vegetables so so this is
where where people will be looking at
and where
the shortages would be felt most
severely if though they really were come
to pass
dw's burger mass in london thank you
and we will have more on the impact on
businesses and the economic fallout from
the blockade
on dw business in around 20 minutes time
now it's been a year since the first
cases of coronavirus were reported
and scientists are still trying to
figure out exactly how the virus behaves
the speedy development of vaccines is
being hailed as a major triumph
it is hoped that they will help end the
pandemic but mass immunity will make it
harder to
study the infection process that is why
one british research company is hoping
to launch a study
using human volunteers willing to get
infected
dw's charlotte chelsea pill has more
at just 18 years old alastair's
volunteering to do what many of us would
find
unimaginable he wants to be deliberately
infected with the coronavirus
he's campaigning to take part in a human
challenge trial
to test vaccines for covert 19.
challenged childs have the potential to
do um an awful lot of good
for an awful lot of people with um
a well not insignificant and minimal
risk
to myself and my health it's a risk that
you know doctors and nurses take on
pretty much every day um like on the on
the front lines of the pandemic
and have been doing for quite a while
now in traditional vaccine trials
volunteers may never be exposed to the
virus
in a challenge trial scientists hope to
study infected volunteers in clinical
conditions
it's in rooms like this one that we
could be about to see a world first
volunteers deliberately infected with
the virus that causes cobit 19.
now volunteers will be quarantined here
for up to two weeks
with safety measures in place like air
filtration systems
to stop the virus from spreading
trial services company h vivo already
runs challenge trials in the uk
but they're yet to be approved for covid
19. so you can see we have
all the emergency equipment that you'd
expect here ecg's
crash trolleys to make the trial as safe
as possible
scientists would first establish the
smallest dose of the virus
it takes to become infected and the pet
will be put just inside the nostril
and very slowly just putting small
droplets
of virus into the nose it would offer a
unique opportunity to examine the virus
in its very early stages
of course these trials are being set up
primarily to test vaccines but there'll
be a lot of
learning benefits that will come out of
these trials as well not just about how
the virus interacts with the
immune system and the human body that
would be key and really important to
be able to improve vaccines and improve
therapies but also
about the disease course itself about
the viral load how quickly it replicates
how quickly it can be cleared from the
body all of these can really help the
management of patients
going forward with vaccines already
being rolled out
h vivo says challenged childs are now
more important than ever
warning that traditional vaccine trials
will become harder
as more of us are immunized
they're excellent vaccine candidates but
don't solve all the answers
to the world's problem of vaccines so
we're going to need a way of testing the
next generation vaccines
challenge studies will be able to still
be able to be used
to test very effectively that the
vaccine is working because they can be
conducted
irrespective of how much disease going
on the community
these trials need ethical and regulatory
approval with a decision hinging on key
ethical concerns
you want to select a group of people who
are themselves very healthy
they are a low-risk group they are true
volunteers
so there's no pressure put upon them or
no undue
bribery in terms of financial incentive
for people to do something that they're
really not comfortable with
only 18 to 30s would be eligible and
volunteers will have to be carefully
screened before they're approved
but not all risk can be eliminated the
long-term consequences way
significantly on my mind
um they're definitely definitely
something to consider um it's part of
making an informed decision about
whether
you know i want to participate in a
challenge trial
but i think for me the benefits of
challenge trials still outweigh the
risks
and i'm more than happy to take the
risks on um you know for more vaccines
more quickly
alistair isn't alone tens of thousands
around the world have expressed interest
in challenged trials
in the hope that the risk of the few
will benefit the many
you